been a dramatic shift in the laws on
abortion affecting millions of women in
this country in North Carolina abortion
rights supporters protested last night's
vote by Republican lawmakers to override
the governor's veto and established a
12-week limit on abortions in Montana
where the state constitution protects
abortion rights the governor signed a
bill yesterday there to Outlaw the most
common method of abortion after 15 weeks
Montana and North Carolina joined other
republican-controlled states in reducing
abortion Access North Carolina had been
one of the few remaining states in the
South with access to abortion now it
joins 19 other states that have either
banned or restricted the procedure and
to get it done Republicans here push the
measure through in just 42 hours